six months after most of america began
locking down coronavirus cases are on
the rise
in 20 states more than 193 000 americans
have died
from the virus and on friday more than
47 thousand new cases
were reported that brings the total
number of infections to nearly six and a
half
million in the united states but more
and more states are taking steps to
reopen
michael george is here in new york which
is planning to open indoor dining for
the first time in half a year
michael good morning jeff good morning
governor cuomo announced this week that
restaurants like this one behind me can
reopen
for indoor dining on september 30th but
only at a quarter capacity
it comes as the nation's top infectious
disease expert continues to raise
warnings
about public gatherings i am concerned
when i see things starting to move
indoors and that becomes more compelling
when you get into the fall into winter
season in an interview friday dr anthony
fauci said it will likely be
another year before things return to
normal if you're talking about getting
back
to a degree of normality which resembles
where we were
prior to covid it's going to be well
into
2021 maybe even towards the end of 2021.
despite fauci's concerns more and more
states are giving businesses and schools
the green light to open back
up effective monday both broward and
miami-dade county
will be moved into phase two governor
ron desantis announced florida's two
biggest counties can now join the rest
of the state in allowing
increased access to indoor entertainment
and education
however bars and nightclubs will remain
closed
but in nebraska where cases are rising
the governor is ending nearly
all social distancing restrictions in
bars
churches and gyms beginning on monday we
sanitize the bus
morning before we leave but there are
signs that many are still
too concerned to even begin a return to
normal
on this school bus in plainview new york
there are typically 40 students
on friday there were only five the
reason why i think these buses aren't
really
filling up with all the kids it's just
basically parents are scared
you know they really don't want to send
their kids to a
situation that they don't know what's
going to happen
florida state university's normally
packed football stadium will be at 25
percent capacity today
that's still 20 000 screaming fans when
the team kicks off against georgia tech
but the tradition of tailgating will be
put on hold
seems to be a little overkill to me but
that's just my personal opinion
but at the university at albany in new
york a rash of positive cases amongst
athletes prompted the school to suspend
all fall sports and the school's
president to warn students that campus
could be
shut down we will definitely continue to
move in this direction
if we find that anyone is endangering
the health
of our campus community and of our
surrounding
communities while limited reopening
should help restaurants more help from
the government appears to be in doubt
on friday senator mitch mcconnell
expressed some skepticism about
congress's ability to reach a deal on a
new economic relief package
dana all right michael thank you